deux d'entre eux se trouvent sur emilie
want to play ya pas qu au fond d'elle
qui me lisent le web vous allez voir
c'est pas du tout la même chose là
l'amour est mort ont été déjà mort de
amy lee howell remarque c'est vrai c'est
vrai bonjour je suis
voilà je suis un livreur de pizza
j'aimerais donner ma pizza est rentré
chez moi et toucher mon chèque mais
d'accord bon c'est un peu tu es la
france est scandalisée devant tant de
types it et à l'appart est retourné à
payer un gros problème avec son
appartement
qu'est-ce qui s'ouvre ça d'accord c'est
bien on montre le chemin
moi je suis pas dans mon gain rapide un
sanglot gras je sens qu'on va faire va
avoir peur un [ __ ] mail
il ya un clown ya un [ __ ] de clown je
vais pas par là bas non mais si on va y
aller oui oui on a du courage avec walt
attend mais calmez vous là il se passe
quoi t on dirait un canular on dirait
que la partie a été aménagé de manière à
me faire peur à le clown a disparu
c'était une grosse boutade de cloud za
la télé sénat aux terrasses quatre sites
ou sanchez de la dirpa naturelles de
manière pas normal de manière paranormal
non je veux juste jouer à ça c'est
emilie qui a écrit ça allait on se casse
adieu schéma crise d'ado c'est l'acte
mémoire cpt d'accord c'est ça qu'on a
entendu et s'il ya le fameux coup de la
personne qui se lève dans un bain de
sang dans la baignoire
bah pas du tout des toilettes aux c'est
quoi ça c'est le clown [ __ ] mais les
gaffes ouais ouais ouais c'est lui
susurre c'est lui à regarder
voila voila il est plus là il est
peut-être dans la baignoire
non je m'obstine avec cette baignoire je
suis sûr qu'il ya quelqu'un finira de
revendeurs ce sera sûrement mois avec la
gorge coupée à quel monde tu poses pas
ta [ __ ] de pizzas sur un objet random
et tu pars en courant comme ça sur ton
bicycle parti en courant sur un bicycle
voilà c'est nouveau bon faisons toutes
les autres portes d'accord un gars dans
lequel 600 personnes sont mortes à la
bck parfait au [ __ ] même et à pas de
chance parce que regardent et voilà que
tu vas faire je crois que ça m'amuse à
tes petits jeux d'enfants là emilie
l'esplanade mina y joue à minuit
au nom et diminué voilà c'est quand tu
te demandes l'heure qu'il est que il est
minuit je veux bien jouer à condition
que tu sois très mignonne avec moi
passons par là assez drôle ça au emilie
elle est là et me calme toi de ton toit
et milices quoi faire c'est que ça n'a
aucun sens
au pied du coup quand on recommence il
est direct minuit voilà et et on sait
que des convois emilie il faut partir la
pièce dans laquelle aurait vu surtout ne
pas rester
alors on va aller par la chanson que ça
c'est une bonne idée a annoncé au sénat
ohlala je me casse je me casse je me
casse les pattes un hummer allez salut
vie je me dis je vais dans la cuisine
et si j'attends là en vrai je crains
rien ne va pas venir d'elle-même a
priori elles jouent à cache-cache si je
dis je suis caché à tour de blessés
regardez je vais attendre la pire idée
du monde mais elle est hyper grâce à cet
enfant qui lui a transmise de si
mauvaises valeurs
allez on y retourne a du courage qu'ils
voulaient je vous dise voulais le passer
outre aux déjà que je vous dise au
revoir qu'on n'a pas de courage banon
non mais pas comme c'est mignon va
l'apprendre par le coup mal à tromper
dans l'eau pendant lui et ça fera un
escargot tout écoutez moi ce que je vous
propose c'est vraiment que on aille dans
la cuisine il ya deux interrupteurs
1la ya là bas si la lumière s'éteint
alors je suis là ça peut pas être sûr
que c'est bon j'ai juste compris ta de
versailles gers voilà là logiquement
qu'est ce que je vais vous lui disiez
qu'on achète un fou et collages la
surface gla maintenant on va prendre ce
point et dès qu'elle va s'approcher de
nous révéler battue doté on attendait la
main en tombant à faire un doigt
d'honneur quand même si ça c'est pas le
destin je sais ce point d'honneur mais
fait comme si pour le bien de ma blague
s'il vous plaît je me casse je me
cassais quoi j'aime pas cherché à
comprendre dégage faut qu au regard des
entités pièces en fait les lumières
peuvent s'éteindre et militer content tu
t'amuses à jouer seul là comme une conne
maintenant ça suffit
papeete par an
écoutez maintenant ce sera pour qu'on
ait deux mille îles à emilie 2010 de
wade dont on est fou amoureux et là
emilie de emilie moins de souplesse
comtesse parce que tout y est fait de
rush mais bon en fait je pense que au
moment où la lumière s'éteint il faut
pas l'allumer il faut juste changer de
pièce voilà vous voyez ce qu'il veut
dire ou pas mais ça c'est quoi ça au
delà le à achraf rejouer la bienvenue à
le monstre non ok c'est le décès et non
mes mails non mais j'en peux plus mais
je bouge plus sains et je suis pas mort
encore à aimer moins de souplesse à elle
va plaire doit avoir comme guillaume
guillaume pley s'attaquera pas vraiment
regardé ml ne voit pas dans noir
actuellement elle est perdue elle s'est
pris les pieds dans le fil d'une
allogènes elle est tombé et s'est cassé
le bras emily haines ambulance c'est
super ce que je raconte qu il est
peut-être temps de bouger quand même un
jour coûte et je vais prendre le bonnet
du courage je prend du courage
[ __ ] c'était nul rien je voyais un axe
que je fasse cette relation tracasser je
fais des visites dû faire des tresses et
c'est vraiment la dernière chose au
monde que je veux plus tard mais jade
est obligé d'en lancer jours re start
allez c'est reparti dernière et c'est
parce que là emilie elle commence à
émuler moins de souplesse médias
[ __ ] [ __ ] con mais quand aussi
abrutis [ __ ] il complètement débile
c'est exceptionnel à savè calmont cela
est là je suis baiser au lavage on a
brain emilie mon gars oh là là elle est
perdue a tu l'as bien dans les fesses un
tu nous as suis dans les cuisines se
feront à brain hausse est portée milito
va voir ça va être encore plus drôle le
jeu entre toi et moi je te jure faut que
cette porte
ian langsdon je peux apprendre aux jets
lampe torche mais où emilie au [ __ ]
t'es toi je me casse je me cache veut
même pas voir août et je veux dire me
demande pas pourquoi je partis sans
mentir à l'oral et lumière [ __ ] on lui
tient tête mon gars c'est sûr et certain
et les graves fâché peter n'a pas eu
depuis longtemps ça me stresse ça me
sens encore plus quand on la voyait mais
l'art n'est nom de torches [ __ ] on est
bien et wayne on a de l'expérience en
jeu d'horreur ml c'est pas une petite
fille de 7 ans malpolis comme toi qui va
nous apprendre la vie peut-être un peu
quand même un champ un peu le malin et
combien de temps il faut tenir c'est ça
la question
je me tiens je me tire je me cache je me
tiens au revoir aux non [ __ ]
oh la la violence la violence on repart
pas là enfin par là on est baisé lâché
en pls dr amar et ministère qua non mais
là on adopte une nouvelle stratégie ml
schlosser quoi optimaux rites ou un
petit sac centre de biche tu me dis où
tu veux un coûteux dans la tête c'est un
cocktail aussi je les vois si elle paye
non une entrée par là et peut-être une
entrée en fait o o
obama l'ancien patineur est venu
troubler atteinte et c'est scandaleux ce
jeu d'horreur doigt à quel moment
quelqu'un peut le finir à moins de
treillières vraiment comme un porc c'est
impossible
ça se trouve c'est la même et me dit que
dans les milliers de wade et brad est
tellement devenu avec dp qui l'a rendue
folle comme sa théorie de merde prenez
ce n'est pas parce que ça nous a plu
parce qu'ils ont très vite dans une
prochaine un sens où on arrête avec les
milli voilà les milices et finit à tout
jamais on s'entraide une prochaine vidéo
porte et on vient de châteauroux bis